[Musique]
à trop jouer à ça passe ou sa casse ça
finit par passer mais passant casse
drôle de réforme qui rassemble une
majorité conséquente d'opposants et
autant de convaincus qu'elle passerait
et après s'interroge-t-on désormais le
prétexte de la légitimation de la loi
par le vote était un argument suffisant
pour baisser les armes à tout loin de la
part de syndicats légitimistes et
progressiste comme la CFDT le passage du
49.3 l'a incité à suivre désormais les
plus radicaux comme la CGT vers une
intensification de la pression
conflictuelle force est de constater que
du bras de fer engagé des coûts sont
apparus coup direct nés des amendements
qui réduisent d'autant les économies
attendues de la réforme coût indirecte
les pertes de salaire de la part des
grévistes coûts d'opportunités comme ce
manque à gagner né de la nécessité de
compenser des dépenses imprévues et puis
il y a aussi cette perte pour l'économie
globale sauf rattrapage ultérieure enfin
il ne faut pas oublier le coût de
l'arbitrage intertemporel et
intergénérationnelle s'ajoute le constat
d'un ressentiment persistant de la part
d'une majorité de Français dans les
sondages convaincu que tout était joué
d'avance il rejette toujours cette
réforme il n'accepte pas ce qu'ils
jugent inacceptable il laisse leur
colère s'installer incorporant détresse
sociale et économiques dues à une
inflation mal maîtrisée cette colère est
comme la pâte de dentifrice une fois
sortie du tube elle n'y retournera pas
elle cherchera des exutoires aujourd'hui
un exécutif inflexible demain des
syndicats s'affichant eux aussi
inflexibles mais jusqu'à quand le
blocage de secteur névralgique pourrait
à pâtir de divergences au sein de cette
inter syndicale à moins que la base qui
est plus radicale ne s'échappe du
contrôle des dirigeants syndicaux dont
certains sont sur le départ enfin il
reste une voie d'expression en
démocratie pour le peuple satisfait ou
non satisfait ce sont les rendez-vous
électoraux à affiche du cycle électoral
naturel les élections intermédiaires
comme les européennes de juin 2024 ou
encore les municipales de 2026 elles
seront l'occasion d'envoyer un premier
message de régler des comptes par
attribution de responsabilités avant la
présidentielle de 2027 un vote sanction
n'est pas à exclure à destination du
sortant les lecteurs en théorie ce dieu
de vengeance et de récompense pour être
très bien tenir rigueur au gouvernement
et au président d'un passage en force de
cette réforme des retraites et ceci
ferait les affaires de l'opposition à
tout le moins du rassemblement national
et de la gauche qui pourrait aussi
prendre l'occasion de proposer une
abolition des 64 ans comme un argument
de campagne électorale en 2027 reste la
droite qui s'attribuant à juste titre la
paternité de cette réforme a toujours
annoncé qu'elle soutiendrait et votre
réforme par cohérence avec ses
convictions sauf certains frondeurs son
sort est néanmoins plus difficile à
anticiper il va dépendre de l'impression
qui dominera dans le jugement des
Français deux hypothèses sont possibles
il y a d'une part une reconnaissance à
moins que ce ne soit une déception tout
dépendra aussi de la trace nesique plus
ou moins forte des ressentis à laquelle
peut s'ajouter l'apparition d'un
possible effet d'asymétrie du blâme ou
ce qui déplaît l'emporte sur ce qui
plaît mais finalement la période la plus
difficile n'est peut-être pas celle de
la lutte mais bien celle de l'après qui
démarre aujourd'hui
[Musique]